semiconductor profit margins have become
obscene Intel has a gross margin of 50
AMD has a gross more of 48 Applied
Materials has a gross margin of 47
Qualcomm has a gross margin of 58 and
Nvidia has a gross margin of over 60
percent also keep in mind that that's
just the average across these entire
companies so if we look at the profit
margins of their highest end products
it's likely even higher than that take
Nvidia for example their highest end
consumer product the RTX 4090 was just
announced a few weeks ago and it starts
at an eye-watering sixteen hundred
dollars even if we use nvidia's average
gross margin of 60 this means that 960
dollars is simply a gross profit but if
we're being real here it's not like all
of nvidia's products have a gross margin
of exactly 60 the more likely scenario
is that the lower end cards like the 50
and 60 series have a gross margin of 40
to 50 percent while the higher end cards
like the 80 and 90 series have a gross
margin of 70 to 80 percent even if we
estimate on the lower end of this and
call it 70 this means that it only costs
Nvidia 480 to make the RTX 4090 and they
sell it for sixteen hundred dollars
leaving them with one thousand one
hundred twenty dollars worth of gross
profit we should also mention that it's
not just these front-facing companies
that have obscene margins either back
into semiconductor companies are also
living it up asml's gross margins stand
at 51 while tsmc's gross margins stand
at 55 considering this it's unlikely
that producing the 49d costs even 200
yet it's being sold for eight times that
amount for perspective even the iPhone
which is likely the most criticized
product in the entire world for having
high margins is estimated to cost 570
dollars to make this means that even the
iPhone is only being sold for two times
its production cost while chips are
being sold for several times their
production cost now you might be saying
that we should look at net margin
instead of gross margin but this doesn't
really change all that much asml has a
net margin of 30 percent tsmc has a net
margin of 40
Qualcomm has a net margin of 30 and
Nvidia has a net margin of 26 percent
this means that even if you include all
of the expenses of research development
marketing and everything else that it
takes to run these companies both the
suppliers and the front-facing companies
are left with 30 margins each if you're
a shareholder of one of these companies
you're holding pure gold I mean Nvidia
stock is up 45 X in the past 10 years
even with the recent 63 sell-off but if
you're a customer of one of these
companies well it's not so great
something that makes this even more
surprising is that chips are not the new
kid on the Block I either most of these
companies have been around for 30 to 50
years so you would think that their
margins would have been worn off with
the time as new competitors enter the
market yet here we are so how in the
world did semiconductor margins become
so obscene
taking a look back semiconductor margins
have always been on the higher side of
things and the main reason for this is
the substantial risk that's involved in
running a chip company you see it the
chip industry is one of the few
Industries in which you always have to
perform simply because it's so ruthless
and the main reason for this is
something called the Moore's Law this
law was created way back in the 1960s by
one of the co-founders of Intel Gordon
Moore based on the historical
progression of semiconductors Gordon
projected that the number of transistors
in a dense integrated circuit would
double every year for the next 10 years
after these 10 years he would revise his
theory to say that the number of
transistors would continue to double
every two years indefinitely this
observation has since become the
standard within the chip industry and
has turned out to be scarily accurate
over the years there have been so many
Skeptics and even experts suggesting
that Moore's Law is dead but you just
have to take one look at this law
algorithmic graph to know that Moore's
Law is still very much alive the number
of transistors on microchips has
literally grown from a few thousand in
the 1970s to tens of billions today
honestly this growth is extraordinary
and is simply a testament to just how
much humans can accomplish but wait a
minute how is this relevant to high chip
margins well the answer is that it's
extremely risky to be in the chip
business because you're constantly
having to innovate at record Pace if you
don't you'll be dead within a few years
here's a list of all of The prominent
American chip companies that have gone
bankrupt within the past few decades I
don't think there's any industry that
has been so Cutthroat for so long take
the iPhone for example which has only
been around for 15 years I don't know
about you but to me the iPhone 14 it
definitely does not seem to be a 2X
upgrade from the iPhone 12. not only do
you have to innovate like no other
industry but you also have an extremely
small margin for error here's the thing
chip companies are solely dependent on
revenue from their chips if iPhone sales
go down Apple can pivot to Services if
Amazon sales slow down Amazon can raise
the price of prime and focus on AWS but
if Chip sales go down chip companies
have nothing to Pivot to
most of them have no contact with the
end user and no forms of recurring
Revenue the only way they make money is
by selling chips and the only way to
sell chips is by Leading The Innovation
their corporate customers have very
little brand loyalty and are willing to
switch at any time I mean Apple
literally ditched Intel do you really
think they're gonna have a problem with
ditching someone like Qualcomm the
answer is no and if none of that
convinced you that this business is
risky just take a look at the Intel
stock which hasn't made a new all-time
high in 22 years so while the
semiconductor industry can be extremely
rewarding it can also be brutally
painful and one of the main reasons
these companies have such high margins
is to compensate for that risk
foreign
companies have always boasted solar
margins when they're on top the margins
that we're seeing today are higher than
anything we've ever seen before take
Nvidia for example before 2016 the
company had a much more modest and
reasonable net margin of 10 to 15
percent but between 2016 and 2019 these
margins skyrocketed to 38 a similar
Trend can be seen at AMD as well up
until 2016 AMD was actually consistently
losing money but between 2016 and 2019
amd's margins flipped from negative 20
to positive 5 tsmca enjoyed a similar
boost as well just during a slightly
different time frame so what happened in
the mid-2010s that cost Sama character
margins to Rocket across the board well
the answer is unprecedented spikes in
demand within the broader Market the
source of the spike is obvious it was
the smartphone Revolution between in
2009 and 2018 the number of smartphones
sold for a year rocketed from 172
million units to 1.5 billion units many
companies saw this opportunity before it
happened tsmc's founder Morris changa
literally came out of retirement just to
make sure that tsmc did not screw up
this gigantic opportunity under Chang's
guidance tsmc would eventually score a
deal with Apple and the company would
proceed to go vertical shortly after the
smartphone Boomer wasn't the only
surgeon ship demanded either we saw
another boom in the PC gaming space
thanks to MD
with the launch of the horizon line of
CPUs in 2017 AMD made a PC gaming more
accessible than ever before by bringing
down the cost of a building on gaming PC
shortly after the launch of ryzen you
could build a solid gaming PC for well
under a thousand dollars and when you
combine this with the insane popularity
of fortnite you had a bunch of casual
mobile and console Gamers switched to PC
but unfortunately this honeymoon period
didn't last that long because Gamers
weren't the only ones that were trying
to secure gpus you see around the same
time that PC gaming was blowing up so
were cryptocurrencies between 2015 and
2017 Bitcoin would literally 100x from
200 to 20 000 Bitcoin dragged the entire
crypto Market along with it which made
it extremely profitable to my ethereum
using Nvidia gpus and these crypto
miners weren't just buying one or two
gpus at a time they were buying dozens
because this wasn't just entertainment
to them this was a business soon enough
Nvidia was not able to keep up with the
demand which led to GPU selling on the
secondary market for insane markups of
50 to 100 percent despite this miners
kept buying gpus because it was still
profitable and this is when a light bulb
went off in Jensen huang's head if
people are willing to pay 50 to 100 more
for our gpus on the secondary Market why
not just charge 50 to 100 more ourselves
with the launch of the 2000 Series this
is exactly what Nvidia would do
initially this actually backfired for
NVIDIA because the 2000 series came not
during the depths of the 2018 crypto
bear Market but Nvidia kept the high
pricing for the 3000 Series which put
them in the perfect position for the
2021 crypto bull market and the rest is
history
though all of these demand factors were
building up throughout the entire decade
a grand slam didn't come till 2020 which
was of course the beginning of the
supply shortage the pandemic took hold
and the factories and Logistics channels
around the world began to shut down and
if you know anything about manufacturing
and scaling you know that it's way
easier to shut down the supply chain
than it is to bring it back to full
capacity and this recovery has simply
been worsened by inflation and recession
fears when manufacturers have to pay
insane amounts for raw materials and
when they're fearful that demand is
going to slow down they're gonna be a
lot more hesitant when it comes to
pumping up production initially this was
a disadvantage as companies could not
meet market demand but over time this
has actually become an advantage when
there's a discrepancy between supply and
demand companies can further raise
prices and simply blame it on inflation
and Supply constraints everyone from
milk suppliers to Apple has been doing
this so it's not surprising that chip
companies have jumped onto the trend as
well but all of this brings up the
question how long can this actually last
whether it's next year or three years
from now the supply shortage will
eventually come to an end not to mention
all of the growth factors that we
previously discussed are slowly coming
to an end as well in terms of smartphone
adoption everyone already has a
smartphone Global smartphone sales
literally peaked four years ago and with
the differences between each smartphone
iteration becoming less and less
discernible it's likely that smartphone
sales will not only stagnate but decline
so Chip suppliers like tsmc will have
less and less pricing power over
customers like apple to make things
worse the crypto Community is moving
away from mining as a whole and
switching over to proof of stake
ethereum just wish the proof of stake
just a few weeks ago and that probably
said a president moving forward now none
of this is to say that the chip industry
is going to collapse semiconductors have
become an essential part of modern
society so the industry as a whole is
not going anywhere anytime soon but with
that being said the chip industry is
extremely cyclical and it looks like we
may have just completed the boom phase
at the end of last year this means that
we're probably just at the beginning of
a long and nasty bust phase Nvidia had
one of these phases after the.com boom
and it took Nvidia 15 years to get back
into another boom phase as a customer
this is probably a good thing as demand
levels out and supply issues are
resolved we'll probably see
significantly better value per dollar if
you're an investor however you better
buckle up because regardless of how long
this phase lasts one thing's for sure
and it's gonna be volatile but that's
just what I think do you think
semiconductor margins are too high
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're hoping that the end of this
insanity is near and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
together ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one